if there are no amendments then the
agenda for today's meeting can be
adopted I would put the minutes of the
9th of October 2023 for your approval if
there are no comments then the minutes
can be deemed
adopted that takes us on to the next
item on the agenda which is a public
hearing on third state collusion
sanctions on Russia and EU policy on
arms exports
for this hearing I would like to welcome
Michael
stalzer the deputy head of the sanctions
unit at the European
commission and Peter vaserman who's a
senior researcher at the Stockholm
International Peace
Institute and also Benjamin henstar a
senior Economist at The ksse Institute
and a member of the Yelm mfow
International expert
group since the start of the Russian war
of aggression against Ukraine in
February 2022 the European Union has
adopted 11 sanctions packages of an
unprecedented scope and scale against
Russia before the invasion of Ukraine
Russia was the fifth largest trading
partner of the EU both in terms of
imports and
exports sanctions aim to reduce Russia's
capacity to wage war the Russian economy
has been in recession since last year
which reduces the kremlin's resources
sanctions will help to reduce Russian
economic resources and undermine its
capacity to wage war against Ukraine
Russian armed stock piles have been run
down sanctions on semiconductors are
having an impact on Russian missile
production which rely in part on
semiconductors from America however the
Kremlin has exploited loopholes in the
policy to import the goods that its
defense industry depends on
thanks to circumvention put in place
with the support of third countries
critical Technologies electronic
components weapons components and jeel
use Goods can be used to manufacture
military equipment and those products
are still getting through the
circumvention strategies are ever more
creative and numerous they involve the
use of front companies and
intermediaries involving countries
around Russia in particular turkey
Kazakhstan buus Armenia and Georgia as
well as the United Arab Emirates and
China Russia also obtains supplies from
Iran and North
Korea in order to close loopholes and to
prevent circumvention attempts the
European Union has worked with Partners
to draw up a priority list of goods
which third countries must not export to
Russia and they have also added the
violation of Union restrictive measures
to the list of EU crimes
in June 2023 an anti- circumvention tool
was introduced as part of the 11th and
most recent sanctions
package Mr steltzer we would like to
know what are the main features of this
new anti- circumvention tool and to what
extent will it thwart Russian war
efforts Mr vetman we would like to know
what strategies Russia is using in order
to arrange alternative supplies and
imports of critical Technologies weapons
components and dual use Goods in
violation of European Union sanctions Mr
H henstock you are a member of the
international working group on Russian
sanctions we would like to know your
standpoint on the remaining gaps in the
current Russian sanctions regime we
would also like to know what additional
me measures could be taken in order to
prevent Russia from getting hold of
technology and Military components from
countries which impose sanctions
including efforts at a bilateral and
multilateral level so I'd like to start
by giving the floor to Mr staler you
have the floor for 10
minutes thank you very much Madam chair
thank you for the invitation and thank
you for giving the commission the
opportunity to speak about this crucial
topic when it comes to implementation of
Russia sanctions a topic to which we
have dedicated considerable resources in
recent months and as you have already
broached which was also part of the 11th
package of sanctions I would like to
reply to your questions by structuring
my intervention today in two parts first
I want to give you an overview of
certain measures that we have included
in the 11th package of sanctions which
was adopted on June the 23rd of this
year and then I would like to speak
about the work of the EU sanctions Envoy
David O Sullivan who is conducting
Outreach with third countries and also
about the measures that the commission
is taking to support this crucial work
by our sanctions Envoy first
though close to the
microphone uh first though I would like
to outline the measures that we have
included in the 11th package of
sanctions adopted on June the 23rd in
particular for measures we have added
non-russian entities to the so-called
ities list in Annex 4 of the uh of the
sectorial Russia sanctions regulation we
have um broadened the scope of the
so-called Transit ban we have revamped
the listing Criterion for circumvention
listings and finally we have given
ourselves a completely new instrument
the so-called anti- circumvention
mechanism which will serve as a big
stick also in our Outreach to third
countries now looking at these measures
individually
first uh the entities list the entities
list in Annex 4 of Regulation 833 2014
contains entities that are linked to
Russia's military industrial complex so
far this list contains mostly Russian
entities now with the 11th package of
Russia sanctions we have added more
non-russian entities so entities that
are not registered in Russia but in
certain third countries some of them are
owned by Russians but they not
registered in Russia to this list why
because we had evidence that these
entities have exported Goods to the
Russian military and we wanted to put a
stop of that to that what does the
inclusion in this list mean it means
that EU exporters cannot sell dual use
and advanced technology items to the
entities in this list next is uh the
broaden scope of the so-called Transit
ban we have had the transit ban already
since package number 10 and we
prohibited Transit of certain goods from
the EU to third countries via Russia if
they concerned dual use and weapons now
we've added advanced technology and uh
Aviation related Goods to this list why
because we have observed that sometimes
when goods were destined for a third
country if they went through Russia they
fell off a truck and then ended in ended
up in Russian arms and this is something
that we wanted to prevent from the out
set for the very sensitive categories of
goods next we have um changed the legal
wording of the so-called anti-
circumvention listing Criterion now what
is a listing a listing is a very classic
EU sanctions uh method basically we put
a third country person or entity on our
sanctions list and that means that all
its assets are frozen in the EU there is
a Prohibition to make funds available to
this person and if it is a natural
person there's also a travel ban to the
EU so a Visa Visa
restriction uh previously we've had this
anti-er convention listing Criterion
already uh since package number 10 you
had to prove the involvement of an EU
operator in the circumvention scheme so
we could not list a third country entity
without being able to prove that there
was also an EU operator involved in the
circumvention of the EU
sanctions um now with this revamp
listing Criterion we have dropped this
requirement it is now enough to
demonstrate that the Third Country
entity played a significant role in
frustrating EU sanctions and we hope
that this will also serve as a signal to
Third Country operators not to
circumvent EU sanctions and finally I
mentioned it before the big stick is the
new anti- circumvention mechanism or
tool which allows us to block the export
from the EU of certain categories of
goods or Technologies to specific third
countries so this is not entity specific
here we can really block the export of a
good to a third country if the third
country has been shown to be under
constant threat of abuse by by sending
these categories of goods to Russia
where we don't want them uh to see end
up um this is a measure of Last Resort
so far no Goods no countries have been
listed it can only be taken if all else
has failed so if the individual listings
have failed that I've have mentioned if
the entity list has failed and if the
Diplomatic Outreach that needs to be
conducted concomitantly and before um
has not produced Ed the desired
results there is also a declaration
annexed to the 11th package of sanctions
where we have an information mechanism
um to keep the council apprised of all
the efforts that have been taken and
that have failed before this instrument
uh can be activated now this concludes
the overview of the measures that we
have adopted in package 11 now I'd like
to say a few words about the important
work conducted by our sanctions Envoy
who has been relentlessly going to uh
Central Asia to the Balkans to the
middle and near East to speak with the
third countries concerned and to make
them understand that we don't want them
to become hubs for circumvention of EU
sanctions this work has already produced
concrete outcomes in certain third
countries where mechanisms have been put
in place to prevent the reexport of
certain categories of EU Goods to Russia
R where we don't want them to see uh end
up now how is the commission supporting
this work we have in particular
published as the chair has already
mentioned two lists first the common
high priority Goods list uh which is a
list that we have in common with our G7
Partners notably the United States and
the United Kingdom which contains 45 HS
codes of goods that are also known as
Battlefield goods and that we do not
want to end up in the hands of the
Russian military or on the Ukrainian
Battlefield this list we use with Third
Country to ask them to stop all
re-exportation of the items that are on
this list but as you are aware EU
sanctions apply only on EU territory and
to EU operators therefore this is
admission and diplomacy we have to ask
them to stop the export of these Goods
the second list is uh
the so-called economically critical
Goods list and these are Goods that
could strengthen Russia's military and
Industrial
capacity and here we use this list to
ask third countries to monitor very
closely the re exportation of these
Goods to Russia because we think it
would be detrimental if they ended up in
Russian hands uh as well both lists are
under constant review we have just
recently published updates on our
website and our colleagues in uh the
director General trade that are in
charge of this important work uh our
colleagues in DJ tud are monitoring
trade flows and Customs flows and here
also we support our sanctions Envoy by
giving upto-date information on which
countries serve as entrepose uh for
re-exportation uh of goods to
Russia um in DG fisma we are in charge
of of technical followup with third
countries so once the sanctions Envoy um
conducts his mission his diplomatic
Mission there is work to be done at the
technical level and we follow up
bilaterally with the third countries
concerned and we also um organized
together with our colleagues in the
service for foreign policy instruments
um Outreach missions in third countries
to inform about the scope the breadth of
EU sanctions
um and also organize TX technical
support missions to third countries uh
to support them in their work to
implement their own sanctions and also
inform them about the scope of EU
sanctions now this concludes my overview
of the work that is ongoing and that
will of course have to be sharpened even
further because as you are aware
circumvention is a real issue it means
that our sanctions are working because
if they weren't then it wouldn't be
necessary to circumvent them we see new
ways of how Russia is trying to get its
hands on critical goods and therefore we
have to be especially wary and follow up
whenever that happens with new measures
and new tactics to stop that I thank you
for attention I look forward to the
discussion and to your
questions thank you very much for that
very clear presentation I'd now like to
give the floor to Mr vetman for 10
minutes thank you very much for inviting
me to provide input into your work what
I will try to do in a few brief remarks
is to say some words based on uh the
facts that we can collect from open sour
sources about the role of imports for
Russia's ability to sustain its military
production and cap capability over the
long term term as I say these um remarks
are based on information uh sourced from
the public domain and they also heavily
leaning on the findings of various other
resarch organizations and media Outlets
which have investigated different
aspects of flows of arms and related
technology to
Russia um first I would like to make
some remarks about the history of
Russian arms Imports over the past
decade before 2014 we saw that Russia
had a showing inter a growing interest
in importing arms from Europe an
indication of a realization by the
Russian military lead leadership that
it's indigenous designed arms were not
always competitive a pathway for arms
procurement that ended when the EU and
EU member states Haled any new contract
for arms exports to Russia after the
invasion of Ukraine in
2014 however of course still certain
types of major weapons components could
still be delivered to uh Russia from
European States uh due to the so-called
grandfather CL Clauses and this uh
included for example dedicated sensors
for Fire Control and aircraft Parts
these were supplied under these pre
20104 contracts but it seems that by
2021 such supplies had ended
at that time Russia was fully dependent
on its own arms in Industry uh Russia
did Remain the second largest arms
exporter Glo globally as it had been
since the
19990s even its arms exports had
significantly fallen over the past de
decade and also are likely to stagnate
further or fall further due to amongst
others Western sanctions and pressure
aimed at discouraging state from buying
Russian arms
from mid 2022 of course it becomes clear
that Russia had been depleting its
stocks of especially ammunition and
missiles at a very high pace and uh had
been looking to augment its own
production with foreign supplies there
weren't however many foreign suppliers
to choose from um up until very re
recently it was only Iran which was to
supply arms and in that case Iran not
having a very Advanced arms in Industry
though that so those those supplies
consisted mainly of relatively simple
drones or flying bombs which were allas
of course used by Russia as part of
their Arsenal to uh ter ter terrorize
Ukraine and uh attack Ukrainian
infrastru
structure there have been of course
strong allegations by the USA that North
Korea has started to supply Ammunition
To Russia too in the past months um and
of course this would be a BL latent
violation of uh the United Nation
Security Council imposed arms embargo on
North Korea as of yet we haven't really
been able to verify the claims by by the
us we still waiting for information
about these wet weapons uh the
ammunition which uh then has been
supplied by North Korea according to to
the US to that uh those turn up on the
uh Ukrainian Battlefield
um other states have not really supplied
weapons to Russia as far as we know not
even China which from the 1990s on
onwards has been one of the largest
recipients of Russian arms has built up
its own arms industry and would
certainly be able to supply arms but as
far as we can see no major complete
weapons have been supplied from China to
Russia in any significant numbers in
recent
years of course as has been Point
pointed out the real is issue right now
is more that as Russia is dependent on
its own arms industry uh it also needs
the components to build those arms and
we know from the uh analysis of weapons
found in Ukraine Russian arms found in
Ukraine that those uh contain
significant uh numbers of uh western or
uh imported components such as
semiconductors microchips and other
items such is B Be bearings to obtain
those items uh Russia has turned to
other states cannot turn to Europe and
the US and anymore and based on analysis
of Customs data several organizations
have been able to show that there is an
increasing stream of uh those kind of
comp components coming from a variety of
states in the world and I'm sure the
next speaker who I know has works for an
Institute which has done very in-depth
research in this particular
as aspect should be able to uh tell us
more about this issue um overall we can
see that the effects of the sanctions
are that Russia has not been able to
import more than arms is just dependent
on its own arms industry um and arms
industry which appears to be Str
struggling to develop and produce
competitive weapons by
itself sanctions therefore do put
enormous strains on the Russian ability
to produce new arm and maintain and
repair existing
ones um however of course this hasn't
stopped Russia from continuing its
attacks on Ukraine and it has shown a
strong will will willingness to also use
all their well weapons or we weapons
that are not necessarily uh uh similar
in quality of that what we can find in
the west the sections also disrupt
Russian arms exports they affect the
ability to produce and serve as weapons
and as they affect the qu quality of
those arms and also the uh lead to
deliveries uh delays and uh NE
negatively affect perception of the
long-term cability of Russian arms
supplies therefore the sanctions further
undermine Russian efforts to maintain
its position as a leading arms exporter
and this hamper Russia's use of arms
exports as a tool of foreign po policy
as a concluding remark uh want to say
that the data which can be collected on
Rian arms Imports remains very scattered
the analysis too there remain great
uncertainties in the public domain about
what kinds of goods and Technology Ria
does import and how it can actually you
use it for maintaining its military
capability um much of the assessments
about that are based on a limited number
of often very good but still Li Li
Limited in number open- Source
investigations and there is no EU or
organization specifically tasked with
monitoring the implementation of the EU
restrictive me measures um and that of
course leads to significant gap an hour
understand understanding of how these uh
sanctions are being violated and
therefore I would like to end with
saying that there is a clear case to be
made for creating more long-term support
for systematic efforts for more
monitoring of implementation of EU
sanctions to inform the per public
debate and of course also the kind of
hearings that we have here today thank
you for your
attention mer thank you very much I now
give the floor to Mr henstock for 10
minutes thank you very much Madam chair
members of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen let me Begin by
expressing my profound gratitude for the
invitation to this hearing and for being
given the opportunity to address
critical issues related to Russia's
continued access to components needed
for its military production and the
pursuit of its brutal war in Ukraine the
export controls regime imposed on Russia
by the European Union the United States
and their Partners is unprecedented in
its scope and targets a country highly
integrated into Global Supply chains
therefore it is not entirely surprising
that its implementation has been
challenging this does not mean however
that improvements to the system cannot
be made in fact they are urgently needed
ukrainians are likely to endure a second
winter of concerted Russian air strikes
on critical civilian infrastructure and
according to estimates by Ukrainian and
Allied intelligence Services Russia has
been able to significantly expand its
production of missiles in recent months
with foreign components playing a key
role furthermore having imposed such
comprehensive export controls it is
critical for the sanctions regime's
credibility to make them work more
effectively with that being said allow
me to walk you through some key findings
with regard to Russia's continued
ability to acquire such
items according to an analysis Russian
trade data conducted by the KF School of
Economics Russian Imports of goods
identified by the European Union and its
Partners as common high priority items
reached 6.3 bill million dollar in the
first s months of the year to put this
number in perspective this is on average
per month not much lower than in the pre
fullscale Invasion period And it
represents a clear rebound from the drop
seen in the immediate aftermath of the
imposition of export controls Russia
appears to have been able to adapt its
Supply chains to the new environment and
done so rather
quickly I would like to focus on two key
areas of concern uh first intermediaries
in third countries play a critical role
first and foremost in China more than
60% of the goods are manufactured there
in addition Chinese and Hong Kong based
entities are responsible for close to
70% of all sales to Russia and finally
more than 34s of the goods are
physically dispatched to Russia from
China and Hong Kong two additional
countries that stand out in terms of the
location of intermediaries turkey and
the United Arab Emirates I should
emphasize that these findings likely
underestimate the role of members of the
Eurasian economic Union for example
Armenia and Kazakhstan as they're not
fully included in our
data the second issue that I would like
to highlight is that a large share of
the high priority items that Russia has
been able to acquire in 2023 are
products of companies headquartered in
countries that have imposed export
controls on Russia in fact they
accounted for almost 45% of such Imports
in value terms those from the United
States play the biggest role in this
cont context they make up 1/4 of all
Russian Imports of high priority items
entities from the European Union member
states stand out less at 5 and a
half% in terms of the specific companies
involved the list represents a who is
who of the world's biggest manufacturers
of advanced electronics I should mention
that many of the companies that rank
high on this list are also those whose
components are often found in Russian
Weaponry captured or destroyed on the
battlefield that Western producers
continue to play such a large role is
encouraging in a way as it demonstrates
that these suppliers cannot be easily
replaced by Russia and thus export
controls remain a powerful tool but it
also illustrates that the current
sanctions regime is not as effective as
we would like what is more countries of
the export controls Coalition also play
additional roles in the supply chain 20%
of the items are manufactured in these
locations close to 10% are sold to
Russia by entities headquar ordered
there and around 5% are shipped to
Russia from there there are several
factors that are responsible for the
challenges that I have outlined first
export controls are a relatively new
tool especially in the European Union
and existing resources are simply not
sufficient for Effective enforcement of
such comprehensive measures for instance
the $6.3 billion in Russian Imports that
I've been referring to are made up of
more than 550,000 individual
transactions it is simply impossible for
implementing agencies to investigate
such a large number of cases and
importantly to do so not after the fact
but rather before the goods reach
Russia second and this is a related
point there are important jurisdictional
challenges if it is the case that an
overwhelming share of high priority
items are produced outside and shipped
from outside of the expert controls
Coalition these Goods never physically
in reach of our authorities including
customer services
this is not to say that such cases do
not exist around 20% of the total is
either manufactured in Coalition
countries or dispatched from there but
for the overwhelming majority the
problem remains third the export
controls regime will never be effective
if the private sector does not undertake
proper due diligence given the complex
Supply chains and the role played by
Third Country entities once a good has
been sold by its producer which may be
located in a coalition country to an
intermediary it becomes incredibly
difficult for authorities to trace its
path and prevent it from reaching a
certain
destination however at this point in
time corporates do not seem to have
strong incentives to step up their
compliance efforts now what can and
should be done to improve the
implementation of export controls let me
start with the private sector since
Coalition countries continue to have
leverage here due to Western companies
involvement these corporates will not be
incentivized to change their behavior
unless and until enforcement agencies
demonstrate a willingness and ability to
investigate expert controls violations
and impose significant monetary
penalties companies say to an extent
rightfully so that it is difficult for
them to know what happens to their
products once they're sold to an
intermediary difficult yes but not
impossible in fact we know from the
financial sector's experience with know
your client and know your client's
client mandates that such due diligence
can be imp mented it does however
require for companies to invest in
compliance structures and changes to the
legal framework will be needed as well
not only to mandate such procedures but
also to permit sufficient And Timely
sharing of information at this point
corporates face a very different
regulatory environment compared to
financial
institutions speaking of the financial
sector we believe that Banks can play a
key role for the enforcement of export
controls as well and this goes back to a
point that I made earlier it is critical
to not only investigate violations after
the fact but also to stop high priority
items from reaching Russia in the first
place the fact that Western Banks
continue to play a substantial role in
the Global Financial system provides
great great leverage here and
importantly financial institutions
already possess the resource it in terms
of compliance departments and experience
for instance in the area of anti-money
laundering to identify suspicious
transactions in real time and stop them
as Supply chains can change rather
quickly Banks and corporates need to
understand patterns rather than Focus
only on specific intermediaries this is
not to say however that third country
intermediaries should not be a focus of
attention we welcome that the EU has now
established a potentially powerful anti-
circumvention tool with its 11th package
and urge that it is employed
aggressively in the coming months this
brings me to a third key element which
is capacity
building export controls or more broadly
technology sanctions are rightfully seen
as a new frontier in economic statecraft
and will only grow in importance
therefore it is critical to expand the
capacities for their implementation and
enforcement this is certainly a
medium-term project but it should begin
now for the European Union it means that
unified enforcement structures similar
to the US Treasury Department's office
of foreign assets controls need to be
considered the current system of member
states being largely responsible for the
implementation of EU sanctions will not
be able to cope with the increasingly
complex challenges related to 21st
century sanctions
regimes before I close I would like to
re-emphasize that it is absolutely
critical to make export controls work
now Not only would this have a direct
impact on Russia's ability to continue
the war in Ukraine but we also have to
ensure The policy's credibility
historically the effectiveness of
sanctions in particular in areas such as
Finance or technology has relied on a
key mechanism over compliance by private
sector entities for companies the risk
of running a file of ofac was simply too
big to accept but if that remains the
case is an open question our analysis of
Russian Imports of common high priority
items indicates that the answer may be
no and if not addressed this will turn
into a fundamental problem for sanctions
as a critical tool of economic
statecraft going forward again thank you
so much for the opportunity to address
this hearing today and I'm looking
forward to answering your
questions thank you very much uh
gentlemen uh for the excellent
contributions which you have just given
us and the additional information I
should like to give the floor to
colleagues now start with the EP
Michelle gerer it's a very valuable
information and uh I think uh it has
become very clear on the one hand we
have set up a good set of rules and uh
and uh measures but the circumvention
and how to control that that is that
remains a challenge the first question
is uh why is it that um when while we
have in the meanwhile clear
statistics uh where a certain amount of
goods were earlier exported to Russia
and not to other countries and now come
the sanctions and now all of a sudden
the same produ is exported to a
neighboring country so Kazakhstan
usbekistan or via turkey or Georgia or
you name it uh and and the competent
Authority who authorizes the uh export
doesn't draw a clear comparison there I
mean I'm I live near Ebor that is the
bundas Fed yeah the the German export
agency and when I talk on the low level
with people they say yes I know this is
company a they deliver to Russia early
and now they deliver to Kazakhstan and
never did it before surprise surprise so
why is it that uh there is not the means
to to stop it and put the
proof that it is not for Russia on this
company I'm convinced it's not only an
issue of we don't know once we have
delivered but there is deliberate
intention to circumvented and so we
should put the the uh the burden of
proof around uh and in many cases it
wouldn't
work the next question is it was named
that who is the one who can actually
follow up in daily life or is there
anybody where whistleblowers be it
people who are working in companies and
you know how the bosses are just busy
rearranging it with Russia through a
third country is there any place where
whistleblowers could say I know my
company is continuing delivering to
Russia but this time it's through can
country X is there a way for people to
to do they know where they can go and
then another I got information also from
Ukraine a a specific question how to uh
uh block uh um the uh the ability of
Russia to produce uh the military their
military needs and that is on uh
computer numerical control machines CNC
Machinery uh that is apparently a type
of machinery uh which uh well
automatizes the production of many of
those goods that the Russians need and
they are major producers are known I
have the list here and I wonder uh uh
whether there is from your side or from
whomever conrete talk and concrete uh
impa impacting on those companies uh
that they do not deliver such uh
products although they are not as such
dual use but it is a general product
that but that can be used also for the
production of such uh military products
so can we do something in in this field
uh and I can supply you with a list of
companies who are doing
it
mer thank you very much Nikos pandre for
snd the T and very clear
presentation of issues I wish there was
more of us here of the MEPS um of course
there's a problem is not in your in your
Bailey Wick uh where did they get the 6
billion each year to buy the arms and we
know that there's still not enough
sanctions on natural gas LNG which is
allowing Russia to finance the war so
that's not in your purview however I
agree very much with the colleague we
probably can't stop all the exports but
if we can focus on the extremely crucial
ones and really come down whether it's a
list of companies whether it's the
microchips whether it's part for the
missiles I'm not a defense expert
because it's going to be difficult
probably their main things bullets
things like that they get from China and
Iran but the sophisticated ones that are
Western there as you say we need more
monitoring uh with specific lists we can
probably do more harm to the defense
industry thank you we'd like your
opinion on
that
Merc pet aich for renew Europe and I
thank you all speakers um who brought a
lot of very interesting and useful
information to all of us um mainly
probably my questions go to the speakers
present in this room
um firstly how many third countries we
have in question which might be
circumventing or taking part in any part
of circumvention of sanctions because
that's a quite a complicated and long
and integrated process how many secondly
to what extent Belarus is involved and
those sanctions what you spoke about
Russia is in Focus because let's be
frank Belarus uh is U uh losing its
sovereignity and um conducted operations
are managed through Moscow so that's why
it's a part of the Russian sphere of
influence my third question is speaking
about EU
companies what kind of impact we still
have uh on those companies which for
different reasons we didn't know we
didn't Supply we used intermediaries
La some of them supplied weapons even by
the end of 2022 because of the contract
and the uh the EU sanctions allowed to
do it for example as company like linr
supplying Thermo Vision which is a
primary weapon in
in the war of today so due diligence is
there anything I mean we can uh enforce
uh on those companies I mean to uh to do
uh um due diligence to the end and not
just produce and forget once it leaves
your backyard uh uh packed and to be
supplied to third countries or anything
else and my final question is to what
extent member states are
Cooperative with the commission knowing
that enforcement of sanctions is in
member states mainly competence uh do
they show enough of interest and uh all
of them are cooperating with you um not
to speak about the candidate countries
which the picture is very diverg and not
necessarily satisfies all of us is there
anything I mean we can do with member
states in this regard and my final uh
remark is on um public policy or
diplomacy in this regard uh it would be
great to have a kind of a a scoreboard
of
Shame okay I mean from you companies and
to do kind of a public diplomacy in this
regard uh informing our citizens and
voters I mean uh who is really behind
some uh you know Shady schemes in this
regard thank you
Merc Joseph
alz Madame CH uh thank you speakers for
your information this is really very
informative for us and very neat uh I
agree with my colleague said and have
this very similar question but I would
like to add little bit uh first of all I
would like to ask you what kind of tools
do you need to close this Loop
holes you what kind of tools you need
more um new uh regulation additional
Personnel because it's shame for me also
that my country Lithuania also stop the
the trade with Russia but increase trade
with Kazakhstan or kiristan
and when we visit with the aad group
Kazakhstan and kistan we hear from the
authorities that they know B control
with Russia and all Goods what is coming
reaching the kazak very easily to reach
the the Russian military industry and
they they can use this PA to
to fight or attack the the Ukraine do
mean that we need some kind additional
new regulation looking for for this St
countries and also the the possibilities
of you uh in institution how we need to
better control and Mr said inform the
our citizens that these companies still
continue the trade with
with Russia through the Kazakhstan
through the other
countries my question is what you need
that you can stop or or or in decrease
the possibilities of of this
[Music]
possibility
well thank you dear colleagues I think
uh we will share the view that we would
like to know what is in our hand to do
more indeed to uh close the loopholes
and make your work more efficient so I
give you the floor back uh to answer
questions and remark starting with Mr
Stela um thank you very much Madam chair
maybe I can start right away with the
last question that was asked what tools
do we need need uh also speaking a bit
about the sanctions framework in the
European Union you're all aware of how
we adopt sanctions they adopted
unanimously by the council um we have
been able to keep a united front over 11
packages of sanctions this was a big
political achievement um and now that we
have these 11 packages they are being
enforced and implemented by member
states in a decentralized model we are a
community of M member states and we are
a community of Law and we all abide by
the rules that we have given ourselves
the commission assists member states
through monitoring and through
implementation advice through guidance
through issuing
FAQs um in this big task but as you have
said the and also as my fellow speakers
today have mentioned the task is
enormous especially when it comes to
export control so what we need in terms
of
um to make this work better is a
concerted effort of everything we need
to strengthen our legal framework
whether a loopholes and this we are
doing quite regularly and constantly in
every sanctions package so far we have
introduced repairs improvements we have
closed loopholes and we will continue
doing so in the future we need more
resources that is very clear on the
member State Side what we are doing now
for Russia sanctions is also as my
previous speaker has said before is
something that we have not done yet in
Russia in sanctions in the sanctions
field before we have relied on the
financial sector um and on certain
export controls so far for our previous
sanctions regimes now we have taken
these unprecedented measures that
basically broad every industry sector
imaginable and we have to equip
ourselves with the necessary resources
to actually control whether these
measures are being implemented that said
not every member state is affected in
the same way by these sanctions there
are member states that are closer to
Russia and member states that are
farther away from Russia and therefore
also the checks that they need to
perform and must perform will vary to a
certain degree um
so it is a question of balance and of
improving on all fronts uh necessary to
make these sanctions work better that
said however I mentioned we are a
community of law meaning that what is
not prohibited is legally
allowed so we observe certain
patterns of trade with Russia and we
adopt sanctions and once we adopt the
sanctions we see the trade pattern shift
to a certain degree because the
sanctions are being circumvented because
they are there so they work to a certain
degree and people go around them so we
see new patterns we react and then we
try to anticipate to a certain degree
what happens next but of course as long
as we are bound by our own legal
framework we need to abide by it and
everyone needs to abide by it I
would maybe stop on this point now and
uh give the floor back to the
chair thank you very much uh I will give
the floor to Mr wizman if he wants to
add his comments to the questions and
remarks raised by the
MEPS um yes uh thank you I think most of
the questions were very much about how
we can better understand who is really
supplying what to uh Russia and through
which channels um and I think as I
already mentioned also in my short
intervention one of the issues that one
has as a researcher in this field and
that's how I can speak as a researcher
is that uh there is a significant amount
of information available but the
resources to uh process that information
and to analyze that and to give the kind
of answers which you are look looking
for remain very Li Limited at least in
the public domain and I think this is
the one thing I can contribute to this
uh discussion is that there needs to be
a lot more re sources to be able to
provide the kind of an analysis need
needed for these types
of public debates to we able to uh uh
further the discussion on how to improve
the uh um sanction regime towards Russia
um and that requires both and maybe
another speaker can refer to that the
the use of networks of um uh researchers
and experts to to deal with this but
also simply the a availability of
resource sources and potentially also um
for the EU to look at options to create
specific EU bodies that are tasked with
um uh monitoring the implementation of
EU sanctions thank
you thank you and finally Mr
heno thank you uh for your questions so
I would uh like to largely focus on on
the question um of how uh such large
quantities of uh common high priority
Goods can still reach Russia despite the
fact that we have all of this
information uh in the end I think it
comes down to the incentive structure
for uh for the private sector uh as I
said earlier we're talking about a very
large number of transactions here a lot
of these transactions are also small in
nature especially when we talk about
semiconductors and other small
electronic items um when uh they are
produced somewhere outside of the export
controls Coalition and then shipped to
Russia via China or Hong Kong or a
similar country um there's no uh reach
for our custom services and probably the
the package is never opened or
investigated at any stage so um tracking
this after the fact uh would need to
lead to incentives for companies to
change their behavior and to implement
uh due diligence themselves if we look
at the list of companies that show up in
this data there are uh you know some
that are major uh electronics companies
uh the top one on the list uh is
responsible for about 280 million in
exports of high priority uh items to
Russia in seven in the seven months of
2023 that we have data for does doesn't
speak to me to any kind of proper due
diligence efforts but the issue is
ultimately that there is no pressure to
engage in them in our view the uh public
exposure or naming and shaming or
whatever you want to uh call it um does
not seem to have had a really big impact
on these companies so the only thing
that that can really work is substantial
Financial penalties if uh they were
found to have engaged in sanctions
violations and we know from other fields
for instance uh Financial sect penalties
for sanctions violations or uh in the
tech sphere uh penalties for data
privacy violations that these do have uh
an impact on on corporate's
behaviors um but so far it doesn't
doesn't look like that is the case uh in
in fact uh after we have published uh
and spoken about a lot of our research
and our findings there are very many uh
financial institutions that have come to
us with questions about the data and how
they can um look into what their clients
uh are doing in terms of business with
Russia there are no corporates uh that
are among the manufacturers of these
items that have come to us um but I want
to close with one kind of more positive
note which is that compared to say six
months ago I think we've reached a point
where uh more authorities now have
access to uh individual transaction
level data uh in various jurisdictions
uh and can actually investigate these um
of course it's a little beyond our
knowledge if this is already the case um
but but that is the key uh mechanism
through which the private sector can be
brought into this um to reduce the
number of transactions that are
occurring still um and reduce the number
of cases that authorities can then focus
on let me close there
or I think Mel G had follow briefly uh
petas uh going out told me and I had the
same feeling we didn't get much of an
answer to our questions uh and my let me
repeat I I I'm aware that it is the
national authorities who have to to do
the job but are we from our side
actually uh checking whether they are
doing this job I I mean I did I came
with this example a company a delivered
to Russia and now is delivering to
Kazakhstan never did it before and so on
and if that is known is there anything
from our side where we and push our
national authorities to to be uh to to
follow up on that one point the other
thing turn round of proof yeah uh uh for
companies who behave in such a way that
that they export application should be
denied unless they really prove uh and
then it's on their side that's all of a
sudden it's a client in Kazakhstan who
has appeared Who Never Was there before
the the other thing um uh was also uh
the question is there on the European
level a a place for whistleblowers to
announce to to give a hint where things
are going wrong and then we could
forward it to the competent authorities
and say have a look on this and uh uh
and there was also a precise question
well if you don't know the answer you
can say you don't know the answer this
group of machineries this computer
numerical control and seen Machinery
that could be helpful to prevent Russia
from being able to produce their uh
military uh uh uh tools that they need
is there anything in this field that is
being
done I think the questions are for Mr
sta to
answer thank you very much for the floor
thank you also very much for insisting
um because those are pertinent questions
the first one whether do we look at
irregular trade data at
trade flows that suddenly are redirected
from Russia to a third country and I can
assure you this is exactly what we are
doing this is exactly the data that
we're looking at this is at the core of
our sanctions envoys mission to exactly
to identify where the trade now goes to
which Third Country and to prevent the
re-exportation of these Goods to Russia
we are in constant dialogue with the
member states on these data we share
these data with member states and we
follow up with member states but it is
as you said before essentially a member
State obligation to implement sanctions
and from the commission side we can
offer all the support we can to make
this work better so this is absolutely a
priority uh as to the idea whether the
burden of proof should be reversed we
take good note uh we are also thinking
about things that we can do to make this
work better in the future so this is
well noted um for whistleblowers we have
a whistleblower tool on our website so
this is a completely Anonymous platform
um if you follow the instructions on the
website your IP address will not be
logged you can completely anonymously
report any sanctions violation to the
commission and the commission will then
forward this information um to the
National competent Authority that is in
charge of the investigation and we also
follow up on these whistleblower cases
so we think this is a very useful and
also low um obstacle tool to get
information on possible sanctions
violations and we also plan to publicize
a bit more in the future because your
question also shows that it is not as
well known as it should be and we try to
get the budget to go out there and tell
people also in third countries concerned
about the possibility to give us a
little hint that uh trade flows are
being redirected to Russia and the third
uh question you raised the computer
numerical control machines well noted if
you could provide us with this in
writing we will uh have a close look if
you look at the two lists that we have
published on our website on common high
priority goods and also an economically
critical Goods list you will find items
that very sound very much like this um
but we have to have a look also in in uh
with our colleagues in DG's trade and
Tuit whether this could be included
thank
you well thank thank you very much to
all speakers I think it was a very
valuable hearing which uh makes us more
aware of what remains to be done thank
you for your efforts thank you for your
research uh I hope that you have the
appropriate resources uh because as you
said it's quite a new phase in uh
enforcement of sanctions and uh fighting
against the circumvention of these
sanctions and it's of course much needed
I close this point on the agenda uh we
need a two minutes break because the
next point on the agenda is in camera
thank
you thank you very
much and